l'uni
[Musique]
voilà pour moi c'est la météo un peu la
musique des journaux et des gens à la
télé on ne sait plus ce soir qu'on
regarde les infos mais je regarde pas
très souvent une fois par semaine à peu
près c'est quoi un jour on fait ça
explique tout ce qui s'est passé un peu
dans le monde un peu partout moi pour
moi le but de regarder quelque chose
c'est j'ai pas se divertir ok après
c'est bien pour les gens qui veulent
apprendre des choses voir les nouveautés
qui se passe dans le monde mais moi ça
m'intéresse que les toisons regarde avec
je vais vous montrer une vidéo vous
allez me dire ce que vous en pensez à
deux pas des champs elysées
un drame a été évité de justesse hier
qu'est ce que t'as tout compris
ben les surveiller les jeunes comme vous
nous avez montré ce qu'ils avaient tout
compris mais là certains oiseaux c'est
difficile c'est vraiment adulte non loin
de là pas un truc que je pourrais pas
comprendre comme ça j'étais sujet simple
c'est facile il ya des choses qu'il ya
les annuler y'a que les adultes qui
comprennent les choses qui sont pas pour
nous j'aimerais que ce soit je ferai
tout et plus simplement
mais il existe un dessin animé qui
répond aux questions en même temps vos
des dessins qui apparaissent il un sens
votre empreinte c'est mieux pour
expliquer comme la pollution et mettait
dessin pour on peut il n'est qu'un
exemple
[Musique]